I will introduce professor Nesbitt now
so dr. Nesbitt has a strong background
in decision analysis risk and
uncertainty
he teaches decision analysis and ethical
analysts analysis here at Stanford he
has a noted expert on national and
international energy and decision making
under uncertainty
in fact he has been in the oil gas power
and renewable decision analysis and
modeling business continuously since the
1970s and is well known as a leading
energy economist and decision analyst
across all the various energy forums
globally his companies have done someone
a work in infrastructure management
telecommunication airline pricing in
fact inventing the original airline seat
pricing software I think you'll mention
a little bit about that today which will
be exciting he has a startup company in
the water remediation and desalination
business the companies he has founded or
co-founded including decision focus
Altos market point Arrowhead and reticle
have been successful in the energy and
water space so today he will be talking
about practical ethics and as I think
we'll see what's unique about his
approach is the way he combines his
breadth of real-world experience with
the strong understanding of ethical
fundamentals and a focus on decision and
action
as we know ethics can get bogged down in
abstraction or rationalization but for
professor Nesbitt it's not just about
thinking ethics but living ethics his
course his course on for the ethical
analyst teaches the ethical fundamentals
and Astin's to apply them by writing a
personal ethical code of behavior as he
said again again to us the best way to
get people to learn and apply and solid
ethical principles is to get them to
write that that their own personal
ethical code so with that I'm going to
turn the presentation over to dr.
Nesbitt thank you very much I'm
delighted to be with all of you one of
the things that we know is that I think
of new decision-making is all around us
isn't it we see it every day and we
would try to do in in the half hour of
this webinar is give some examples of
some analysis of these situations and
what we might do about it and this is
one that affected me personally second
cigarette smoke this was several years
ago and I was giving a decision analysis
course to industry helping people think
about its advancing on the timer
thinking about this and during the
breaks a senior executive from one of
the tobacco companies took me aside and
said you have a Stanford PhD yes I do
and here comes the request from this
person we need someone with your
credentials to testify in our behalf
you certainly believe that secondhand
cigarette smoke is not harmful don't you
it's very diverse it's very it diluted
and transient we have a lot of money we
can pay to you for testimony this like
this we please do it for us
we'll make it well worth your while
decision analysis with some low
probabilities will be really convincing
and convince people that secondhand
cigarette smoke is not a liability we
should be held accountable for it's not
about thoughts mind step sets tractions
or philosophies that ethics is about
actions and consequences without
decisions what is ethics even mean
number two ethics is about people not
about things the sick our cigarettes
make decisions the cigarettes have any
ethical content whatsoever we think not
we think that things are not what are
engaging in actions or behaviors it's
people the third thing is ethics is
ultimately personal related to personal
decision making or personal contribution
to group decision-making again without
decisions what does that thinks okay
ethics needs to be driven therefore by a
well-crafted ethical code we think in
the course that we teach everyone writes
a personal ethical code of action based
on the solid ethical principles and
theories that we put for it and that
code is a key deliverable in the course
and it's proven to be one of the most
significant penetrating emotional things
people can do people have told us that
years later many people carry and modify
their ethical codes for many years into
the future that's an interesting comment
that we get back from students years
into the future as we think about ethics
we like to think about the decisions
related to everyday life and business
life as falling into three basic
categories are having three aspects one
is Prudential and the Prudential aspect
of decision making is what we teach in
decision analysis what's the best thing
I can be doing what benefits me the most
prudence making good decisions and
maximizing the probability of good
outcomes what do I gain and what do I
lose so we like to look at these ethical
decisions such as the testimony on
cigarette smoke from a Prudential point
of view one of the things when we do
that we we come up with a notion that
Prudential decisions are those that
involve regret geez I wish I'd had done
that I could have made a lot more money
those kinds of things so when you're
thinking about regret you're thinking
about prudence that's the first Olympic
ring of ethics we call it the second one
over on the Left we want to think about
legal aspects and legal aspects have to
do with are there any laws for against
this and then we give a lot of attention
to the notion that the legal ball or the
legal ring is quite distinct from the
ethical ring isn't it the way we like to
the way we like to emphasize this is do
you want these types of people the
people who were responsible for laws or
mandates writing your ethical code for
you and most students and most people
say no I don't want that I don't want a
political process a lawmaking process
writing my ethical code I want to write
my own ethical code and I want to think
about the law at the same time but
distinct from ethics okay when you think
about it that way one of the things we
talk a lot about and we talked about in
a another course that we've offered here
at Stanford is okay what part of your
ethical code would you be willing to
impose on others by force if your
ethical code doesn't doesn't
something like child sexual abuse would
you be willing to impose that on others
by force I would if your ethical code
says item and baibe alcohol would you be
willing to impose that on others by
force I wouldn't so we like to think a
lot about legal as part of an ethical
code that's imposed on others by force
that's not what we really want to talk
about completely when we talk about
ethics
once we've fought through the Prudential
and legal aspects of these decisions the
last one is ethics and ethics boils down
to right and wrong acceptable and
unacceptable when we're thinking about
ethical decisions we're thinking about
remorse we're thinking about lying awake
nights wishing perhaps that we had not
done that or we had done that so remorse
is associated with ethics regret is
associated with prudence so let's go
back and think about how I thought about
the the testifying on behalf of tobacco
companies on secondhand smoke
potentiality was that prudence
Prudential yeah I could have made a heck
of a lot of money doing that I could
have gotten a lot of notoriety and so
forth so from a Prudential aspect had I
taken that assignment and done that it
would have been very much in my personal
economic interest legal any legal
implications of that decision probably
not probably not unless there was some
perjury involved okay
ethical right and wrong
had been ethical would it have been
right for me to lend my support to that
kind of a thing would you have done it I
didn't do it I turned it down when I
look back on that is there regret well
there's a regret when I think about the
bikini area rewards that I might have
gotten but there's no remorse I know I
did the right thing and these kinds of
ethical decisions are with us every day
aren't they a little bit of background
on me my father was the general manager
of a large open pit copper mine in the
state of Nevada place called wheat
Heights Nevada you'll note the arrow on
the diagram that will become significant
in a few minutes okay that large open
pit copper mine has been closed for
roughly three decades it's now a
Superfund site it pollutes groundwater
the gravel and other stuff blows around
in the wind and and and gets around that
valley kind of an interesting question
is did my dad and his colleagues do
anything unethical engaging in the
mining business
when was it Prudential yes was it legal
yes was it the right thing to do did
they know that they were going to
pollute did they know that they were
going to to harm the environment they
did not know that the state of
information that they had in those days
was very low on groundwater on migration
surficial water and so forth I would
argue there was nothing unethical given
the state of information that they had
would it be unethical to behave that way
today it might well be because we know
more so ethics is is rational as well I
do want him this is kind of a funny
story
using a Will Rogers quote when I moved
from Nevada to California here at
Stanford I lowered the average IQ of
both places when I finished at Stanford
the first job that I got and this is in
the public domain so I'm not divulging
any confidences was that the
Environmental Protection Agency
and there was a pesticide named DDT many
of you had known about that which was
canceled a couple years prior to this
the next one in line was a pesticide
called chlordane which is very effective
against termites and corn worms and so
forth the motivation for canceling it
was it may be carcinogenic and it may
have long-term harm in the environment
that would you have taken this job I was
not ethically sensitive in those days it
was my first job I did take it and I
have no expertise in the in the human
biology or the environmental biology my
job was to figure out how much economic
dislocation would happen if the
pesticide was canceled so I don't think
I did anything unethical now the next
point to be made over and over again and
in the in our everyday ethics in our
course we really worry about this and
that is ethics day extends well beyond
business doesn't it we very much
consider that let's think of another X
to ethical question would you cheat on
your spouse or your significant other
would you do that would you hook up at a
bar or at work what if you were
committed to a significant other would
that make a difference what if you were
a free electron uncommitted in the
ethical codes that our students write
here they focus on this some would some
wouldn't ethics is personal it has to do
with decisions you remember the arrow in
the mind I grew up in the state of
Nevada where prostitution was legal okay
and the question that comes it's an
ethical question is would you go to a
brothel or equivalent would you do that
the county that I grew up in Lyon County
Nevada still has prostitution illegal
and if you look at that-air about seven
miles up there was illegal brothel the
famous Mustang Ranch was pretty close it
was maybe 40 miles up that road
one of the things we noticed is those
places always had cars in the parking
lot and my dad used to complain they're
my employees cars would you do that it's
a question for your ethical code isn't
it
and when we think about that we offer
three other distinctions that we need to
think about in considering and pondering
and analyzing the ethics of the decision
we might think the first dimension is
lying deception when we think about
going to a brothel or we think about
just spoiling the environment are we
lying are we lying to others are we
lying to ourselves so lying
understanding deception line is a big
part of understanding ethics stealing
violating property is the second aspect
are we doing something to violate the
property of others are we taking it in
the third aspect of ethics we know this
one harming violating the person of
someone else most ethical decisions and
most dimensions of those can be
categorized in lying and deception
stealing and harming and we give a good
deal of attention in our analysis to
these things it's kind of free on each
of these dimensions there's a good
chance that you're making an ethically
respectable decision okay
this raises another point and that is
that morals are quite different from
ethics aren't they our morals what's the
definition of more a it's what's
acceptable in your society in my society
as a child a lot of guys would go to
these brothels they still do it was
consistent of the mores of that society
you weren't rejected for doing that for
on them on a social basis but is it
ethical would you do it that's the
important question turn
a couple of business scenarios that I've
personally been involved in one was a
natural gas research organization what
they were doing was levying attacks
against ratepayers my company was
approached hey you've got a great bunch
of models and analysis here certainly
you can come in here and help us
convince the regulator to tax rate
payers at an even higher level so we can
do even more R&D and you can tell
everybody how beneficial that is would
you do that for us please when you come
in and get us more money would you have
done that job we didn't do that job
here's one that we did climate change
National Energy Technology Laboratory a
government body this is in the public
domain we need some electricity modeling
to show the global warming from Ohio
coal generation is deleterious to the
environment over the long term we've got
a lot of money for that we'll make it
worth your while would you do it so
let's talk about Prudential as a
Prudential sugar you can make some money
doing this is it legal sure is it
ethical I didn't have an ethical problem
with him and that kind of simple in us
was i lying no was i stealing no was i
harming no here's one that's a little
more murky and this one occurred some
years ago I had sold a company to a very
large service firm I became an employee
for a specified minimum period of time
and when I joined like most people I was
required to sign an ethics and conflict
of interest professional practice
agreement he did and there was a meeting
of the minds on those agreements in
ethics we talked a lot about meeting of
the minds what do you expect me to do
and what am I going to do I knew what
they meant and I agreed with what they
meant I think doing those kinds of
things is not ethical probably not legal
as well one of the provisions in those
agreements as in most that I've seen was
that I was not to engage in bribery
gifts considerations kickbacks
commissions conflict of interest and
certainly no blackmailer
and as you think about what we teach in
in the ethical analyst and think about
these agreements you're much better
prepare to understand these agreements
and what they mean legally and ethically
it wasn't long after I joined that I was
summoned to a conference call and quite
a few partners on that call the company
had been initiating a very large
proposal effort to accompany the person
responsible at that company was somebody
that I knew and I had worked with her
she was a VP in that company in a
previous job in a previous company the
conference call went something like this
Nesbitt you know their VP Betsy that's
not a real name I do I work for as a
consultant a couple years back did she
like you I never really asked but I
inferred so let's cut to the chase we
want this job and it's competitive we
want you Dale
to get Betsy and her husband up to La
Cantera not really the name of the place
that we went to it's a PGA golf course
in a resort for a fully paid luxurious
relaxing weekend away from the kids
fully paid by us by the way is she happy
with her husband I was asked hmm we need
to invite her up for a brief business
meeting on Friday and then we'll give
her a luxurious weekend with their
husband because we want her to be
positively disposed towards our proposal
we'd like you to do deals we'd like you
to approach her you know her none of us
knows her and we'd like you to propose
this would you have done this would your
ethical code have allowed you to do this
with that legal agreement that you
signed with this company have allowed
you to do this well I said I can't do it
I agreed not to do this kind of thing
and there were a couple of people that
were pretty furious telling me I was
letting the company down we need this
money to pay the salaries of our people
it's a big contract there's no I in team
you've got to be a team player you've
got to do this
and I replied as an ethical analyst and
said suppose they'd ask me to rob a
liquor store would I do that would you
expect me to do they said well of course
not
and I said we were asking me to break a
contract that I have with you and to
violate my ethical code the answer is no
I thinks it's very easy when we think
about it that way is that would have
been Prudential for me to do it I don't
know would it have been legal for me to
do it not clear not clear maybe not
would it have been ethical for me to do
it no isn't a sales commission the same
thing those of you who work under
Commission you'll do a lot of things to
get a sale will you do anything
unethical don't talk about that in a
minute and the minute is right now not
long thereafter we submitted a proposal
to the North Dakota Highway Department
we won't talk about what it is but it
had to do with managing their
infrastructure and so forth we worked
and worked and worked and submitted what
I considered to be an honest and
attractive proposal at a budget of 1.5
million dollars the most fictitious but
the point is made on the day of the
award I phoned him up and I asked how
did you like our proposal they said we
loved it it was the best proposal by
four we want to do business with you
guys it's head and shoulders above the
other proposals that we got there were
five others however you're five times
the budget of that aren't you smart
enough to know that what you do is you
bid way below your cost if you ever want
to get in the door here and then you
look for ways to augment the budget you
can't tell the truth in these bids what
you have to do is reduce your cost to
the point where your cost competitive
and then look for change orders so give
you one chance here and if you can do it
I'm not even sure if you can reduce your
bid by 80 percent look it will
reconsider you you'll be out of the
competitive range
would you do that would you write a
proposal to do something that you know
you can't do I didn't I said I can't do
that it's just not okay to do that is it
legal yeah
is it Prudential yeah is it ethical is
it right no it's not I'm representing in
writing that I can do something that I
know I can't do for that for the budget
that they have there's a really
interesting structure out there called
the eastern span of the San Francisco
Bay Bridge
it was bid on exactly that kind of basis
the original contractor bid a billion
dollars on it it came in at over six
billion dollars and it was all change
orders I would argue and in the public
press people knew they could never do it
for the bid that they offered but they
offered those bids and looked for the
change orders is that ethical as that's
something that you would do another
personal vignette from my own practice
was a international resource company
it wasn't an oil company but it was a
company like an oil company I'll call
him as a pseudonym River Bend company
this is very insightful they're one of
the larger international resources
producers in the world they're
headquartered out of the u.s. we had a
fixed-price contract with this
organization through amounts are
disguised everything was agreed to we
had a meeting of the minds we knew what
we were gonna do they knew what we were
going to do now the client who was not
really named Bob but we used that
pseudonym all along the way kept asking
for more hey the boss wants to
understand co2 better let's get it in
there and understand let's run ten more
scenarios let's get the client point of
view and there the boss really wants to
understand co2 remediation all good
objectives right and so we said that's
good we're glad to expand the scope to
take care of it and Bob kept assuring us
don't worry you'll get paid no sweat
just get going just get going I'll take
care of the contract and paper I'll have
it to you now
we can't wait just go we must have had
that conversation five or more times
with me getting nervous that we didn't
have a contract for this performance
it was unequivocal insurance assurance
we came to the end the client called and
said the proverbial good news bad news
preamble fantastic job our CEO JB loved
it however I'm sorry I didn't budget or
enable the initial work all along the
way even though I told you I would I
can't do it now there are realities my
management won't accept it they aren't
expecting I can't do it you're gonna
have to accept the original budget as
payment in full you're gonna have to
forego the 50% additional budget that I
told you that I would get you and I
didn't but Dale we were happy I know
that I verbally authorized this and I
know you did it and delivered it I know
you really should get that additional
money because we agreed alas I just
can't come through this is final take it
her lady what I said was this isn't
acceptable you gave me your word you
told me that you were gonna pay me I
know I gave you my word but I didn't I
can't I won't you deserve it I'm not
gonna do it then it got really tough you
said if you send me an invoice for the
original mountain I'll get it paid if
you enforced me for a dime oral say
there's no contract and they'll drag out
over a major hassle it might be a month
or two months maybe a year before you
ever get paid anything I said you lied
to me he said take it or leave it that's
final I said I'll accept that I don't
have a choice I've already paid my
people and I need to cover and you go
sorry I let you down I didn't get the
paperwork done because management was
complaining about the cost of this
project and I wasn't going to raise my
hand and ask for more money I'm sure you
understand no bum I don't so here's the
funny part I sent an invoice for 150
caves I agreed I got a check two weeks
later for 150 K on Monday on Wednesday I
got a second check for 150 K by accident
they had made an accounting error and
they paid me twice
so I had in my hands more than we had
agreed to including the authorized
budget in the middle I had his life in
my hands the night in my shoes what
would you have done what would you have
done
Prudential II what would you do you kept
the money legally probably okay
ethically what would you have done
now assess I did was when I called him
up said hey man thanks for the $75,000
tip that was great what you sent you
paid me twice I didn't know you liked
the work so much outcomes the ethical
confession of sins oh my god there goes
my job I'm gonna get fired you're gonna
keep the money and blow my budget I know
you'll do that I might be forced out of
the company over this I never told
management a word about it
I expanded scope on you knowing that we
wouldn't pay etc etc it's every confess
sin after sin lie after lie after lie
one of the things we talk about a lot in
the ethical analyst is if you grab one
paperclip the whole stack comes just
like lies you tell one lie the whole set
of lies follows doesn't it what did I do
and I had a lot of arguments with my
colleagues the key was my words I'll
accept it I didn't say I might accept it
I said I'll accept it I have no choice
I've already paid my people I need to
cover it as I won't be paid so I said
I'm not dishonest I told you I'd accept
150 K even under duress I dropped that
second check uncashed in the mail back
here this morning I won't be paid for
doing your project and your dishonesty
is responsible for that he said I can't
believe you did that but there's a key
comment I said yeah I know Bob you would
have kept the money
I know you would have this is the first
time you've actually told me the truth
on the project it brings up another
when we talk about in ethics is your
word your bond in my ethical code which
I don't share my word is my bond and in
student ethical codes that we write in
class they're very personal level kept
in strict confidence nobody sees anybody
ethical sees anybody's ethical code and
you'll see why okay did I do the right
thing here's a famous one and this is
Harry Truman at the end of World War two
we talked a lot about consequentialism
and ethics but here was one where there
had been a very bloody war that had been
going on for four years estimates of
deaths in World War two or seventy seven
point five million people around the
world died Harry Truman said it'll be
five hundred thousand to a million
people will die if we have to invade the
Japanese mainland if we drop the atomic
bombs those people won't die okay people
in Japan are dying anyway under the fire
bombings that were doing and so he said
let's do a benefit-cost analysis of this
and the benefit-cost analysis was very
simple we save half a million to a
million lives okay and we saved the fire
bombings on their side so dropping the
atomic bombs that the United States
ended up dropping was actually in that
positive and he that's a
consequentialist ethical argument and
consequences means you do a benefit-cost
analysis of lying or harming or anything
else and if the benefits exceed the cost
it's ethically respectable to do it that
was the analysis that was made I would
suggest if you're interested in this
read Richard Rhodes the making of the
atomic bomb we teach a lot about
consequentialist ethics and we teach a
lot about action based ethics and that
was a classic example that we try to
analyze and think through one of the
other things that we know is that if we
accept public office or run for public
office
we will be consequentialist in our in
our decision-making we will have to
assess aggregate benefits and cost
and for things like dropping an atomic
bomb maybe we don't want to do that
maybe we want to say we don't drop it
under any circumstance no matter what
the consequences okay no pesto here's
another ethical issue we're seeing all
the time in the United States would you
own a handgun it's an ethical to own one
is it ethical to carry would you apply
for a permit and if you got it would you
carry it this brings up a point in
ethics that imposing harm or on a
person's person or property is clearly
unethical but what about imposing risk
this imposes a lot of risk on people and
imposing a risk has ethical consequences
too doesn't serious ethical consequences
we think that imposing risk on people is
unethical would you own a male pit bull
unspayed and put the male pit bull in
your backyard
that's imposing risk on people many
people think too would you do it a
notice in the commentary we have here I
keep saying would you do it would you
make that decision and that's the
centerpiece of ethics isn't it it's what
do you do but what do you not do the
thing we focus on a lot and we see it
everywhere white lies I find it
difficult to discern lies by color but
white lies are the harmless lies that
are told to save the feelings of another
person the classical white lie is honey
do I look fat in these pants what are
you supposed to say from an ethical
perspective are you supposed to say no
you look really slim you look ravishing
you're supposed to say I love you anyway
no matter what your weight is and one of
the things that we note is that there is
ethical content in your answer if you're
willing to lie about the small things
are you willing to lie about the large
things very interesting white lines may
not be as innocuous as you think
romantic involvement in the work
place is another issue that we we see
time and time again isn't it we see it a
lot and and back in the in the old days
maybe 10 years ago there were no
corporate rules against it now there are
does that matter doesn't matter whether
there are rules against it or not in
your ethical code that's the rules are
kind of a legal thing right it may be
illegal to have this certainly against
the rules or you've signed a contract
not to do it but suppose you didn't have
that is it okay I'll give you one other
example for my practice this has
happened in everybody's practice I was
working with the client organization the
team of about four of them and about
four of us and one of the clients
persons was a lady named Ann junior
professional in their organization
single attractive very forward in her
behavior she became very flirtatious
with one of our senior guys okay and
particularly at this the the dinner and
drinks events that you invariably have
after work they they left arm in arm
from one of those events and didn't
resurface till the next morning
now Gary our guy was married with kids
she wasn't
mmm was her behavior ethical was legal
was it Prudential only she would know
right
what was it ethical was his behavior at
the call here's the other one was my
behavior ethical I didn't tell anybody
about it now I know that in modern
companies you have a you got to tell
about these kind of things inside your
company would you tell your senior
management that that that Gary had
breached his contract interesting
ethical questions aren't they
it's one of my favorites because I've
been so tempted so many times how many
times they beat men at a hotel and you
walk by a table and that's what you see
and you look over there and this is a
conference for hairdressing and makeup
so it's not your conference you have no
idea who these peoples are is it okay to
say you know they're not going to miss a
couple of shrimp and they're kind of a
cup of coffee and some nice condiments I
think I'll just go over and help myself
the marginal cost is zero to them right
that's the rationale is it okay to do
them
more generally if somebody else doesn't
need something is it okay for you to
take it that's a really penetrating
ethical question it's a question of our
dais No
so do belly up and take it I don't I
don't I couldn't I wouldn't be able to
sleep nights it's not my property I
don't do things like that but I see
people belying up all the time okay
let's get by this one this would be how
are we doing on time we're pretty close
to the end okay this would be the last
one many of you have read about
Elizabeth Holmes and fair nose and she
was the one who as their nose was the
one who said we only need a tiny drop of
blood and those of you who have needle
phobia just give a little finger prick
and we can do everything with that tiny
drop of blood that we could have done
with the large vial of blood that we
normally would draw from your arm and
send through a standard laboratory and
there was a number of allegations of
fraudulent behavior and so forth like
that and which we'll get into in just
one minute ultimately she and her CEO
were alleged to have committed fraud
with regard to the directors and to the
investors in their company because what
they had been doing was taking a
standard-sized vial of blood from people
and rather than putting it through their
own technology that didn't work they
allegedly sent it out the standard
laboratories and then reported it back
and this gets into into into a word that
that we hear all the times called spin
would a spin mean these lie one of the
things we talk a lot about in the
ethical analyst in our analysis of
ethics is let's don't let you form is
instinct for us euphemisms like lie like
racial epithets things like that these
are all lies you can't be meaning that
because the meaning is so broad spin
what is spin
reading from a paper article On January
29 footage from company parties and
internal interviews made the whole thing
come alive and helps paint a full
picture of what was happening inside
this now in famously secretive shop this
is this the sentence that really got me
I think one of Elizabeth's greatest
skills at least in terms of fairness
initiative is her ability as a
storyteller a storyteller
what's his storytelling it's a liar
right is a story this this is a
euphemism okay she was able to be so
convincing because she convinced herself
she convinced herself that the
righteousness of her cause was so great
that if they cut a few corners here and
there or did a few bad tests that they
get it right ultimately and save lives
that idea that the ends justify the
means isn't particularly well
time-tested is it
the interesting question is would you
hire her would you hire was it
Prudential for her to do this turns out
it wasn't was it legal turns out it
wasn't but was it ethical is it ethical
to say well we'll get it right next time
we'll represent the final objective that
we're we're looking for rather than the
realities along the way so when we
ethics we really want to think in
summary of flip to the summer and then
we can conquer this was another one just
not very briefly my company developed
the original seat pricing algorithm for
United Airlines and others it's well
known it's a very interesting ethical
question that comes out of that what we
help that airline do was charge
different prices to different people for
the exact same thing a seat on an
airplane from LA to New York is that
ethical that ethical to charge different
pieces dramatic people dramatically
different prices for the exact same
thing it happens all the time
ok let's conclude then with some of the
final thoughts that we have and then
we'll open up the questions and then
ethical codes and ethics the way I see
it have to be actionable you actually
have to be able to do something or not
do something based on your ethical code
so abstract theoretical hypothetical
non-actionable console consequences
don't really cut the mustard my ethical
code doesn't have cure world hunger in
it how can they ever do that be a nice
ethical thing to do but it's not
actionable the other thing is ethics is
not coercive you can't force somebody to
be ethical ethical is ethics is relates
to the decisions that you make well no
one's watching you when no one's
coercing you it's what you do when you
turn out the lights and really make that
decision and the point of ethics is not
to bash others on their ethical behavior
that's not what it's about it's about to
formulate what's ethical and what's not
what's right and wrong and what's not
which decisions are justifiable one of
the other things that we've perceived
its decision analysts is that ethics may
well be rational and self-interested a
lot of people say well if your ethical
you're like lambs to the slaughter
you're exposing your soft underside to
unethical behavior by others I'm not so
sure that's an empirically valid
assessment quite the contrary
ethical behavior tends to be I think a
rewarded by ethical behavior the
famous book by Robert Axelrod from the
80s called the evolution of cooperation
talks about reinforced positive behavior
induces counterparties to behave that
way
the ethical analyst is replete with
these kinds of ethical situations we
don't talk politics that gets in the way
we don't talk labels we don't label if
people talk labels in the class we
eliminate the labels it's about not
about promoting a specific brand of
ethics consequentialism action-based
that they expert you ethics etc we do
present a broad range of historical
thought on ethics but it's about raising
ethical sensitivities and providing
tools for making the right decisions
ethical decisions for those are you
won't be taking the course I would
strongly recommend you grab the book
that was written for this course about
ten years ago by retired professor
Ronald Howard and Clint Korver ethics
for the real world it's available on
Amazon for about 20 bucks Kimball 30
bucks hard we use it in the course the
last point and thank you very much for
your attendance at the at the webinar
ethics professors complain all the time
ubiquitous Lee no one ever actually does
this they love the course but they never
do it and what we found is that there's
a much higher possibility of people
behaving act ethically when they write
an ethical code why is that it's like
practicing the piano you figure out what
you need to do what are the exercises
you need to do you make a commitment to
do that that's what an ethical code is
it's getting the principles together
getting a good understanding of them so
when the ethical situations occur the
speed of occurrence doesn't get in the
way of just saying oh the heck with
ethics I'm just going to do what's
Prudential so you know you mentioned
about the tools for ethical decision
making and I know here and elsewhere
you've talked about disciplined decision
making that happens around ethics this
sounds like the first
is writing that ethical code what are
some other ways to achieve that
discipline and what are some of the
barriers to acting ethically so just to
bring up a few examples you mentioned
for instance the money and you got the
extra one hundred fifty thousand dollars
return that money for some people maybe
they would need that money you know they
couldn't afford but not be paid and
maybe you couldn't afford to not be paid
so that seems to be a huge barrier of
potential in your choosing between
acting ethically by returning the money
your word is your bond and perhaps
acting ethically by supporting your
family
another example that a few people came
brought up was you know how do you
influence change change or influence the
ethical direction of an organization
another individual and you're lower on
the food chain in a company so again
broadly speaking how do you how do you
what are some tools for being
disciplined in your decision making a
living by that ethical code and maybe
more specifically what are some of the
common barriers that you help students
anticipate and think about ways to
overcome those are good questions and
and there's several of them let me start
mine how do i how do I make ethical
decisions better and and I go back to
say a concert pianist what do they do
what they do is they understand the
principles that they have to perform by
that step one and step two as they
commit to using those principles
perfectly personally not perfectly
personal that number three they practice
and practice and they write it down in a
code okay one of the best ways to behave
ethically on an individual basis is to
not sidestep one and to understand the
principles that drive your personal
ethical code and rehearse those
principles so when these decisions come
to you you can make these decisions the
question we always get is that's great
you know in five years into my career
I'm a junior professional in my
organization I can't do anything ish you
can't you can either refuse or in the
extreme agree to participate in certain
things but you can help people
understand that you know this kind of a
thing
say concealing an environmental
transgression
this has consequences okay if people
find out it's going to be a lot worse
for you don't lie about it and yeah the
law department doesn't want you to lie
one of the biggest impediments to
ethical behavior is the reward and
penalty system you're rewarded
provincially for going along and getting
along and you can be penalized pretty
prudentially for not going along and
getting along I think one of the one of
the main things that you can help people
understand is the intersection if there
is one between the ethical ring and the
Prudential ring we all in our careers
were looking for promotions we're
looking for good reviews and so forth
and we really need to think if we're
willing to engage in unethical behavior
to get there like claiming credit for
the work of other people that kind of
thing so really carefully think through
just as a classical piano player would
would do what are your principles how
did they pertain to you and then how do
you communicate those to other people so
it sounds like in the class itself a lot
of these ethical dilemmas the purpose is
not necessarily to reach a consensus in
the class but I use them as an
opportunity to sort of reflect on your
own reactions and thoughts about those
as you formulate that absolutely the the
ethical codes that I've seen in the last
decade are pretty diverse and disparate
on a number of these issues that we
talked about some people are pretty self
focused they feel they're good people
and they don't really need an ethical
code just so you know I'm not gonna lie
I'm not gonna steal and that's it
other people are very reflective they
worry about gender ethics they worry
about end of life ethics they worry
about convincing other people in their
in their companies that to do a B and C
would lack ethical value do you see big
differences in these codes what we want
people to do is think through the
principles that are going to guide their
ethical code and then to codify it it's
the best way to increase the number of
decisions that you make ethically so
the coats are intensely personal it
sounds like it may not really person so
when you've encountered these kinds of
ethical dilemmas in a team environment
and there's a difficult different
ethical perspective I mean what is your
responsibility I may I suppose it's
written into the code itself how do you
resolve those kinds of ethical conflicts
between personal ethical codes most of
the time when you're in a team and
you're in disagreement about what's
ethical or not ethical the the most
important thing to think about is do I
disagree on the information or do I
disagree on the values in decision
analysis we teach that decisions are
comprised of three things
alternatives information and values many
times in the team like if we're arguing
about say climate change we're not
disagreeing on the values what we're
disagreeing on is the information let's
make sure that we understand where we
may be disagreeing on information and
clarify that and quite often you'll find
that on these teams you're not really
disagreeing on the values at all you're
just agreeing on the alternatives to get
there there's huge progress that can be
made when you we are able to to to to
pick apart the three bases for
decision-making and collectively think
that through
interesting okay so in terms of if in
terms of the the organizational barriers
to I guess ethical decision-making I
mean so there's there's it sounds like
often teams don't have the often it's
not an ethical disagreement it's one
about information yeah
are there other organizational barriers
that are built in or I guess another way
to ask that question and we talked about
beforehand is if you had a magic one you
could change one thing about you you
know organizations in the world or the
u.s. nonprofit for-profit government
what would you change about them in
order to increase ethical behavior let
me answer there's two questions out of
the first one is what is the biggest
impediment what I see in in the United
States and Europe and Asia where I've
practiced the legal issues are so
expensive and difficult and creates such
a penalty structure that law firms
almost managed companies anymore
and that's an impediment to ethical
behavior you're told not to say things
you're told not to do certain things by
your law firm and we've got to be and
because you don't want to plead guilty
to some sort of an infraction de facto
so that's a difficult one to get around
so you're saying just as the way
Prudential and ethical decisions can
come in conflict yes oh can the legal
and ethical as well movie absolutely if
you thought you were gonna be sued for
something your law firm will tell you
don't disclose that and do a B and C
don't do eat you know that's very
difficult the the second question was I
forgotten please if you had a magic wand
so what would be the one thing you would
change about these institutions yes
okay everybody personally my the biggest
thing they take away from our course
even if they they just sit into a
lecture like this don't lie don't lie
okay don't lie it's real easy
no white lies no green lies no yellow
eyes my black lies no red lines don't
lie and some time just go through your
day I think how many times you lied
for me personally I was pretty will use
a euphemism fast and loose with the
truth sometimes it's not ok if you learn
one thing from this course it's do not
lie so it's almost keeping maybe a
journal or law so they do a couple days
just doing a personal accounting of
Familia my ethical code doesn't have
that in there but I do and even white
lines even small lies taking credit for
other's work sitting quietly when you're
given credit for someone else's work
don't do that
correct the law well we're almost out of
time and so I want to just come back to
the course but a couple people asked you
to name the book again so I'm gonna I'm
gonna jump back to a couple people asked
about this and I guess there's a fault
if there's one thing so don't lie but if
there's one other thing you would
recommend for everyone to do even if
they can't take the course what would be
that one thing that you you would think
they should do help people think through
the discrimination of three Olympic
rings on the decisions you're about to
enter the prudential the ethical and the
legal and what we do quite often we've
all done this is we say well it's so
prudential this is such a good deal for
me forget that little ring on the lower
right we'll just do it the reward and
penalty structure can get in the way of
good ethical decision making short term
thank you everyone for your time i'm
sorry if we didn't get to all the
questions they were excellent and i you
know hopefully everyone will continue to
engage with these these issues so thank
you again
you